all right pop sky is uh sky is the limit
um it was it was just great stuff
tonight wemi dunking on that finish
while still near on the ground gotal in
at least 50 of the
states I don't get that one
n could Ed could have done without that
one and good job
dzel um so I think I mean in this game
saw you saw
why uh Giannis with those two MVP
credentials and a champion doing what he
does and a glimpse really at at a guy
who can change the landscape of the
league in Victor wiim minyama what was
your biggest takeaway from watching what
they were both able to do tonight W WB
to me I've only seen him play three or
four times but tonight was really
impressive cuz he was trying to compete
with Giannis and you can see jannis is
like no no no no not yet young F that's
what was really impressive and what was
really good about ER they played against
each other a lot you know me Kenny were
in the back like oh man I want to guard
him and he I want to guard him but so
for me this was wy's best game from a
competitive standpoint cuz he was really
competing against Giannis and I love
that aspect of it but man I tell you
what though o look at that that's
impressive but I will tell you man the
Milwaukee Bucks they got to address
their defensive Wes because everybody
was scoring at will and you can only
expect jiannis and DNE you can only
expect so much out of those guys because
you're trying to compete you're
competing you're competing to win the
championship and if you don't get better
defensively you're not going to beat the
Elite
teams well M just has to continue to get
better this rookie season you know we we
we know you were the number one pick we
know you're going to be a pretty good
player but you just have to keep keep
continuing getting better and then soon
you're going to take the crown from y
soon LeBron will be leaving in the
league of be yours but you have to get
better get better get better stay injury
free and just keep continuing to get
better uh I agree with Coach Griffin he
is the future of the league if he
continues to get better and you heard
pop in his in-game interview with Jared
Greenberg and he asked him if he ever
seen anything like that in the third
quarter what what he was able to see
from from wemi and he just said no and
and so he's doing a lot of things that
you do not see on a on a day in day out
basis yeah and you know pop is learning
what he's already great at like there
are certain things when you come into
the league you say well I'm great at
this I think pop is still learning what
he's great at because he's so versatile
sometimes you kind of you're putting him
in too many places instead of the place
he needs to be at this early stage
secondly the Spurs eventually are gonna
need a playmaker if you watch the game
everything is one his ability to get it
he needs someone to get him an easy
basket there you know Giannis gets easy
baskets playing with Dame Lillet and
when he was with Drew holiday be prior
to this he get he got easy baskets
LeBron James plays with Anthony Davis he
can get easy baskets by cutting to the
rim and things of that nature Shaq
played with Kobe you played with Kevin
Johnson like there's no easy
basket on an nightly basis for wmy there
occasionally but not on not a steady
diet I played with two great por guards
Kevin Johnson and one eye Maurice Cheeks
they always got me six to 8 to 10 12
points a game easy because nobody can
live on contested what what if wmy
played with a Jason kid oh my God it
wouldn't be fair you know you know how
much I love Jason kid if he played with
a Jason kid or or even Maurice Cheeks or
somebody like a PR a John Stockton yeah
oh my God it wouldn't even be fair I
mean but but the Spurs like I say
papovich coach papovich is the right
coach for that situation because you
know we live in uh in this Society where
everybody wants everything really really
quick Spurs are they're
rebuilding they are they're looking at
the next 10 years not the next two years
and man this league I I would say you
had to be impressed with womy tonight
because he really competed against in 26
minutes in 26 minutes yeah 125 121 your
final score um Milwaukee now 7 and2 in
games decided by four points or less
meantime the Spurs have lost 13 in a row
in single digit games
uh I'm a hit I'm going hit him with that
[Music]
stick